Hype for the third entry into the John Wick
franchise has been steadily building over
the past few months, and excitement is only
going to grow now that the first reviews for
the film are in.
The minute studio Lionsgate lifted the restriction
on reviews for John Wick: Chapter 3 – Parabellum,
critics quickly published their thoughts on
the Chad Stahelski -directed actioner.
Reviews for John Wick: Chapter 3 – Parabellum
are glowing, helping prove that the John Wick
movie series continues to outdo itself where
other follow-up films fall flat.
JoBlo's JimmyO gave Parabellum a perfect score,
praising the film for its inventive action
sequences and its heart-pounding plot, which
sees our titular assassin John Wick, played
by Keanu Reeves, trying to outrun those who
want the $14 million bounty on his head after
he killed a member of the international criminal
group the High Table in John Wick: Chapter
2.
JimmyO writes:
"This third chapter is one of the most thrilling
flicks you'll find in theatres so far this
year, and somehow, they've found new ways
to bring men to their knees.
The violence is near operatic, capping off
one of the best damn trilogies ever made […] It's
impossible to remember the last trilogy that
worked nearly as well as John Wick - aside
from perhaps Lord of the Rings, which is timeless.
The third film continues to build the mythology
in the most satisfying of ways.
It's a ferociously fast and immensely breathtaking
adrenaline ride of a flick!"
He added that John Wick: Chapter 3 – Parabellum
is, quote, "certainly in the running for one
of the best films of the year."
Robert Kojder of Flickering Myth was another
critic who stamped Parabellum with an impeccable
five out of five stars.
He said of the film,
"Put it this way, if George Miller's Mad Max:
Fury Road was the legendary filmmaker showing
youngsters how it's done, this is Chad Stahelski
firing back.
Much like Chapter 2, Chapter 3 leaves you
begging for more.
At this point, the John Wick movies are becoming
a new drug, so go get your fix.
Prepare for more than war, prepare for constant,
exhilarating anarchy."
Chris Nashawaty of Entertainment Weekly had
wonderful words for Parabellum, particularly
how its action scenes, which are a mainstay
in the franchise, were choreographed.
He also applauded actresses Halle Berry, who
plays an assassin named Sofia, and Anjelica
Huston, who portrays the Director of the High
Table, for giving performances that add, quote,
"a jolt of unexpected emotional weight" to
the movie.
Nashawaty made his feelings about John Wick:
Chapter 3 abundantly clear in the final lines
of his review:
"I don't mean to give the impression that
John Wick 3 is anything grander than a gorgeously
choreographed, gratuitously violent action
movie.
But as gorgeously choreographed, gratuitously
violent action movies go, it's high art."
Uproxx's Mike Ryan exalted Parabellum as the
best film in the franchise, due in large part
to how the movie expands on the series' existing
world and mythology without ever feeling bogged
down or less fun than its predecessors.
"Like John Wick himself, this third chapter
feels like a lean, mean, fighting machine
- and, yes, it's the best film of the franchise
so far, even surpassing the first film.
There are moments in John Wick: Chapter 3
– Parabellum where I thought to myself,
'Well, I've never seen that before.'"
Chris Evangelista of Slashfilm called Parabellum
"...a bone-cracking, horse-kicking, dog-biting,
book-smashing, ax-throwing action masterpiece."
while Fresh Fiction's Courtney Howard described
it as
"...an eye-popping, jaw-dropping, show-stopping
next chapter that extends the world-building
beautifully, whilst assigning meaningful resonance
to the character-driven action."
USA Today's Brian Truitt was largely impressed
with John Wick: Chapter 3 – Parabellum,
calling it a "solid continuation of the killer
franchise that makes James Bond look about
as hardcore as Peppa Pig," though he did admit
that the supporting characters - like Laurence
Fishburne's Bowery King, Asia Kate Dillon's
The Adjudicator, and the big bad Tick Tock
Man, played by Jason Mantzoukas - were a little
underdeveloped.
He also wrote that the final act was a bit
messy.
"This third movie brings both the operatic
action and intriguing exposition, though misses
the greatness of Chapter 2 because of a convoluted
last act and underdeveloped supporting characters.
[...] In the Wick-verse, a bloody action usually
leads to much more trouble later.
As long as that's at the heart of this series,
a pretty good Chapter 3 still equals insanely
explosive, two-fisted exhilaration."
Alissa Wilkinson of Vox also brought up the
point of John Wick: Chapter 3 – Parabellum
lacking some, quote, "narrative intelligence,"
but argued that whatever the film is missing
in that regard, it makes up for in style and
visuals.
"Should the John Wick universe have a more
coherent mythology?
Should it come up with some kind of a point
it wants to make?
Should it, in other words, try to become a
smart series of movies at some point?
No, I don't think so."
"Oh."
"Parabellum is just as satisfying as its predecessors,
and not just because of the Tick-Tock Man.
It is not, to be clear, a smart or wise movie
- it's just a really fun one."
Of course, no film is entirely perfect.
Though the overwhelming majority of critics
applauded for John Wick: Chapter 3 so hard
that their hands went numb, there was one
who wasn't completely blown away.
Variety critic Andrew Barker felt that Parabellum
was difficult to watch in that it features
so much violence and doesn't let up.
"What do you need?"
"Guns.
Lots of guns."
He did, however, give kudos to director Chad
Stahelski and the entire creative team for
making something so visually masterful.
"On a level of pure craft, then, John Wick
3 is unquestionably great action filmmaking
- certainly the most technically accomplished
of the series thus far [...] But as masterfully
executed as the action is, watching two-plus
hours of mayhem without any palpable dramatic
stakes, or nuance, or any emotion at all save
bloodlust offers undeniably diminishing returns."
By and large, the reviews speak for themselves:
people are picking up what John Wick is putting
down in Chapter 3.
If the film's critical success thus far translates
into big bucks at the box office, perhaps
Parabellum won't end up being the end of the
John Wick series.
After all, according to Uproxx's Mike Ryan,
Parabellum "doesn't really try to play coy
about a fourth movie."
Decide for yourself if John Wick: Chapter
3 – Parabellum gets your blood pumping when
the film hits theaters May 17.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about John Wick
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.